I leaned over the center console in my car last week and hurt a rib.
It's quite a lot, but I think it's and I think it's broken is that this is new for me concerns.
Um, yeah, I mean, we even if you don't have cancer, you can break a rib.
I can't tell you how many ribs I broke.
I mean, I broke every figure in each hand.
Um, some more than once and broken, you know, ankles and, um, and uh, uh, fibulaism.
So, uh, this has nothing to do with pathological fractures and nothing to do with the testences to bone.
You could break a rib doing something like that.
You could spray a rib doing something like that and it could hurt just as bad and take longer to heal than a fractured rib.
But always you do want to consider, you know, is it a pat?
Do I have a pathological fracture?
Um, get an x-ray, you know, well, that's not very much radiation.
If you have a car fracture that can take an x-ray for you, um, you can see if, if there's a break there.
There's nothing you could do for the broken rib itself. So if you didn't have cancer, I would tell you not to go get an x-ray.
Because there's not a whole lot you could do for it, except maybe use a rib belt to just let it heal the problems every time you breathe.
You're in a coastal muscles move that rib and a cause of irritation.
So ribs take a long time to heal.
They just do spray or fracture.
When you have cancer and you, it's something seem to crack easily and you're concerned about it, then you're concerned about do I have metastasis to the bone causing a weakness in that bone.
And so that's when you might want to do an x-ray to see if there's a fracture because then you that might spark you to go and look if there's any metastasis to that bone.
And why would you need to know that? Well, because it might spark you to look at any other possible boli metastasis and might spark you to do some other form of treatment like radiation to a metastatic tumor to the bone because that's always going to be litigants, always going to be bully destructive.
But if you're like, I'm not doing that anyhow, then, then don't do that. You know, I've had people that hurt something and then it's like, well, I can live with this, but should I look at it.
And you know, sometimes it's like, well, maybe it's God's way of showing you that there is metastasis there so you can take care of it.
So you don't want to just quote a quote, band up on everything and suffer through something, just pray about that whether this is whether God's trying to show you something or heck, you know, there's times you fall down and maybe it's just me.
But sometimes I fall down and hurt myself and it's just because I'm clumsy or it's a work into art. So it doesn't mean you bounce trying to always tell you something that's sometimes you just try to tell you to use things, at least for me, sometimes just tell me slow down.